families are rallying around a durango
high school student tonight yeah josh
ocampo was elected homecoming queen but
reportedly got into trouble for wearing
a pride flag kate houston live in the
newsroom tonight with the changes that
parents would like to see after all this
kate
yes homecoming is supposed to be a night
of celebration for many high school
students for josh ocampo they say it
quickly turned sour a mom i spoke to
says many students were visibly upset
and want changes to be made
[Applause]
[Music]
durango high school senior joshua campo
was elected homecoming queen to a
roaring applause in this video you can
see them pulling out a pride flag after
giving an impromptu speech ocampo says
they were told it was a campus
disturbance a mother of two durango high
school students says this is
unacceptable and may make other students
fearful to be themselves they need for
somebody to love them accept them period
they're beautiful as they are every
child and for you to do that
and set that back
and make that kid be afraid of who no
don't be afraid of who you are josh
shine the ccsd code of conduct and dress
code regulation does not mention flags
lopez wants the school administration to
apologize to ocampo and their family
ocampo says they're at home until school
administration speaks to their parents
i reached out to the school district for
more information on this and i'm waiting
to hear back we have also connected with
ocampo and you will hear from them
tonight at 11